welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where they all float Pennywise
the dancing clown from Stephen King's
Story it is arguably one of the most
fascinating villains in horror history
whether it's its creepy smile
shape-shifting ability or the sinister
side that makes it one of the most evil
monsters ever put to film you have to
agree that it has a certain allure about
it to celebrate the release of it
chapter 2 this year I thought I'd break
down everything that you need to know
about Pennywise including its role in
the book and its history this is full
spoilers ahead so if you don't want
anything potentially ruin for yourself
about the film then I highly suggest
that you turn off now without the way I
just want to give you a huge thank you
for clicking this video I hope you enjoy
it now sit back relax and let's get into
my breakdown of all things penny wise ok
so the first question that I want to
clear up that I've seen after my videos
is did penny wise used to be a real
person this is because in in chapter 2
we see Beverley looking at an old
photograph that appears to show penny
wise as a person in old dairy well to
get rid of any confusion this is in
penny wise or what we at least know it
to be whilst this man did exist penny
wise used its shape-shifting abilities
to take this man's form in order to lure
in the children of Derry this old
photograph in the trailer still has some
significance as it showcases how long
penny wise has been in dairy for Stephen
King based its appearance on Ronald
McDonald Bozo the Clown Clarabelle and
John Wayne Gacy the serial killer are
sometimes donned a costume it uses this
appearance because it can quickly lead
children into a false sense of security
which is why we see it appear as a clown
so often the creature it is actually
billions of years old and is known as a
glamour it originates from another
dimension outside of the universe known
as the macro verse its real name and
species are called deadlights
but as the losers Club are unaware of
this they say
refer to the creature as it there refers
to itself as the eater of worlds which
probably means that it has drifted
through the galaxy going planet to
planet carrying out the parasitic
attacks until it's trained the location
of all its resources whilst most assume
that Pennywise is male it's actually a
female and in this story we discover the
creature is pregnant though it's killed
before it can give birth it landed in
what would come to be known it's dairy
thousands of years ago during an
asteroid crash and it lived in the area
allowing humans to build a town around
it so that it had a regular food source
it is as much of dairy as dairy is it
and thus the creature cannot leave the
town it has a hibernation pattern of 30
years and its awakening is normally
marked by the huge tragedies such as the
Kitchener Iron Works explosion which
killed 88 children during an Easter egg
hunt it has the ability to shape-shift
and it uses this power to scare the
humans which live in the area according
to it frightened flesh tastes better
which is why it spends the majority of
its time attempting to scare people
Pennywise primarily hunts children as
these are easier to frighten and because
the fears of adults such as bills and
money worries are difficult to manifest
as whilst the creature seems complex
it's only goals are to sleep and eat and
when awakened it tends to operate for
roughly a year before returning to its
slumber it eventually becomes arrogant
and begins to taunt and torture its prey
for months before eating them which
ultimately leads to its downfall if use
humans as below it and thus allows them
to escape sometimes as it doesn't really
see any difficulty in taking them
further down the line due to its psychic
abilities it's able to carry on this
pattern of behaviour as it can influence
the police into not investigating the
disappearances too deeply and thus it
flies under the radar it can control
minds as well which is why the adults
seem quite nonchalant to the missing
children and why Beverly's father cannot
see the blood in the bathroom along with
the name Pennywise the creature also
uses the alias Robert gray which is a
nod to real-life child cannibal Albert
Fish whilst it can be horrifying at
times penny wise also sometimes uses its
appearance to charm children it does
this to Georgie and Henry Bowers both
of whom manipulates and the latest look
at the film we see that it has changed
its appearance slightly which showcases
that is trying to lure children in
rather than scare them as it probably
still has regrets over the losers Club
now the main difference between the
story and the film is that in the
adaptation it is barely able to pass as
a human whereas in the book it can
completely blend into society it's
famous phrase you'll float - also
differs in the movie as in its lair we
see the children's bodies that it has
taken floating in the air whereas in the
source material the phrase you'll float
refers to the children's corpses
floating in the water of the sewers
whilst we never see its true form the
creature manifests as a giant spider at
the end of the story and shows its dead
lights these lights come from an
interdimensional realm and send all
those who look at them insane it really
doesn't have a true form no and its
appearance is normally decided by the
onlooker in the source material it
appears as a werewolf - one child whilst
at the same time appearing as a clown so
it's difficult to decipher its actual
appearance as it has no true form it
cannot be killed by conventional means
and thus the only way to defeat it is
through the ritual of chert as the
creature feeds on fear only courage and
love can overcome it and when the losers
Club reunite their strong connection
with one another allows them to form a
psychic connection that destroys it this
rids the town of the creature and the
group are able to go their separate ways
after finally foot building their oath
now there are more things that tie into
the law of the creatures such as the
giant turtle but that's for another
video
as I just wanted to focus on Pennywise
for this one obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on Pennywise and what you
think the scariest thing about the
character is comment below and let me
know and if you enjoy this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my full breakdown of the recently
released it Chapter 2 trailer which will
be linked at the end this is the channel
for people who were mad into movies so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]